see I haven't turned my phone on with
this chuckit people are very confused
about how this virus spreading the key
is to just not touch your face okay do
not touch your face like I have an itch
right now just lightly do it with a pair
of scissors I mean be careful if there's
an earthquake my eyeball is gonna get
scooped out but I can't even do makeup
now without touching my face see the key
is to just make sure you're about six to
eight inches away at all times it's not
that hard look at that see you beautiful
oh not that hard
see I shadow it's not really my color
maybe a little later on the touch there
I feel like I need maybe a little bit of
deep fog this is a color called deep fog
up just goes on right a little bit of
beautiful shimmer in it
don't forget eyeliner okay it's very
easy see usually when I put on eye
makeup I touch my not gonna do that I'm
not gonna do that because I'm not an
animal so you take something if you need
to pull the skin of your eyelid back
just do not use your hands under any
circumstances see I don't know why you
guys are complaining about this it's not
that difficult lip liner not that hard
you guys are just I feel like
everybody's being such a baby about that
[Music]
all right so you just delicately line
the lip delicately just right at the
edge of the lip okay and then you want
to apply your lipstick so we're inside
the liner uh-huh if you're having
trouble moving the object just move your
face like have the object stay still and
just move your face to kind of fit you
know thing okay beautiful um let's see
uh you have to make sure to do your eye
mascara see that not coming within six
inches of my face
people act like this is so hard they act
like it's so impossible to not spread
germs it's not that difficult
just a little feathering of the eyelash
you want to do the lower lashes really
gonna sort of glamorous look you know
the lower lash really brings out the
pupil you know it really brings out all
the veins in your eyes makes your
eyeballs of extra apocalyptic to kind of
match match the news okay see where's my
deal where is my endorsement deal let's
go call me Revlon hit me up I'm
available
I even think that there are ways to eat
without touching your face you know like
I want this almond I'm not just gonna
put my hand in here and then put all
over my face that'd be ridiculous
here's how I eat almonds now okay that's
so far they're just so difficult so just
make sure your hands do not touch your
face I think I wash this pretty good
we'll see you soon I won't my Cheers